hey guys we are here today at the Xbox
press showcase and we are about to
interview Phil Spencer who is the head
of Xbox so it's going to be exciting
[Music]
a
lot of games a
lot of you not too many
never do mitigator like that 42 game
honors engage in that
22 with console exclusivity
from xbox 1s and xbox one X and then we
got to unveil
Xbox one X the world's most powerful
console
true 4k gaming and chosen very very
beautiful games on our big 4k screen
that we built and at home people had a
4k stream so they could see the visuals
in 4k at home as well so is that was a
good day it was a very good day I felt I
felt the energy of the fans in the arena
so strong
the ODE original xbox backward
compatibility got a big cheer I always
loved that but it was good considering
most of the RTL from here yeah very
clear to know what feels directed to the
forties oh
yeah I think about the I don't think
there is one strategy for Asia I think
Asia is I shouldn't be saying this to
you but I would say it's it's different
markets with different tastes in gaming
I was proud of the
Asian presence on our stage yesterday we
talked about the Japanese games but we
also had games from Korea games from
China in our state on our show and and
that's that's important to me having
developers in many countries building
games is the best way to attract develop
gamers in those countries because there
are those developers in the country are
the best at understanding the tastes of
the gamers in those those markets and we
can also offer them the ability to reach
worldwide success
on xbox and windows across across
and all of the geographies which I think
can be helpful so strategy is to find
local developers to build their games on
their platform so black desert people's
ah black desert that you know this I
mean well yeah I'm surprised to see like
this is why you don't think about an MMO
because it to the Cheerilee PC yeah and
then it's coming to console so that was
way cool yeah yeah with I thought it
looked very good on stage to
the question about the name yeah come on
X yes why did you continue the name Xbox
one yeah and also YX yeah so from the
beginning I wanted this console to be
part of the Xbox one family so any game
that you had purchased any controller
any accessory that you had from your
Xbox one would work on an Xbox one x so
the Xbox one is the family name of that
of that console from xbox one Xbox one s
the X comes from a slogan we had on the
original Xbox as part of that team and
there's no power greater than the power
of X and
letter X is important to us on Xbox and
I thought it was a great way we have
Xbox one Xbox one s and with Xbox one X
we were able to
remember where we've come from
because I think our history is important
as we think about our future
we also liked the codename Scorpio I
think there was a lot of excitement
around that and we were we'll still work
to find a way to make Scorpio an
interesting part of the history of this
project and we will we'll kind of talk
about that but to have a name that
matched is the family of products
because most of our console customers
will buy this year will buy s it's the
lower price console for families or
people who are
casually interested in gaming the price
point is very important this console the
X is built for a customer looking for
the most premium experience true 4k
gaming no compromise 4k native frame
buffer the most beautiful console games
anyone has seen but that's not the
console for everyone many people are
happy playing on an S and that's great
for us so it's important to remember the
family of consoles when we think about
Xbox one
but I think in the title or separate
ecology inputs tetragonal punchy working
like interval if it was not marina
shield because yes she's a we need you
to look up or
do you congestion so at the conference
there are variety of games but there's
no punches Hey
he's always tough on me he's always
tough
what would you feeling about the lineup
let me talk about haloing gears first so
the
coalition team the three four three team
coalition works on gear 343 works on
halo I visited both of those studios in
the last month and have seen the great
work that they're doing in fact gears 4
is here in 4k if you haven't seen it as
beautiful but in the future they're both
working on future projects that we'll
talk about
I was very proud that we could have
42 games on our stage
the longest a press conference we've had
more games than we've ever had and not
have to rely on Halo and Gears I think
that showed diversity in our portfolio
you know and I know that you will see
Halo and Gears and yes right if those
games will come but I love seeing
crackdown I love seeing state of decay
sea of thieves is showing very well out
on the floor new IP for us like super
Lucky's tails brand new game the next
Ori game and I love or in the blind
forest I think it was great which the
biggest game from us that very few
people talked to us about his minecraft
but minecraft is bigger than any game
that anybody will show at this year's e3
and we showed minecraft in 4k which I
thought looked fantastic but
rest assured haloing gears are in good
hands and we will hear more about those
stories in the future
ok so you talked about that what
compatibility and also the number of
games that you know yeah so personally
what is one game time so I think from
the Xbox cataloging you would want to
win back today before one day and
whatever was the game that you're the
people would do the most out of what you
announce it
so let me give three answers because
there's another announced that we did
today
that's an important game from our past
but not on xbox today we announce Age of
Empires
definitive edition is coming back so the
original Age of Empires brought up to
modern
visuals supporting Xbox Live is coming
in Age of Empires for us has been such
an important franchise for Microsoft
before Xbox great way back so that we
announced that at the PC gamers show
today but I think it's an important one
and I know there are many people in
Japan that have loved age of empires and
other places in Asia that have loved age
of empire stuff I wanted to show crimson
skies which is why that was the game
that we showed from the original Xbox we
have a lineup of more games coming on
the original Xbox but crimson was a game
for me from the original Xbox with a
great story a great setting a great
world and I also think visually it holds
up pretty well to today's games but of
all the games that we showed
I think worry in the blind forest will
always hold a special place in my heart
so or in the will of the with the next
one with a piano player coming up that
he was actually he's the composer of the
music for the game so he is Gareth is
actually the person who composed all the
music for the first game under 17 so
having him was an honor to have him on
stage playing and then I just maybe it's
just me but I find everything that's
perfect about gaming is in Orion like
the sound the visuals are so special
like and the game is such a true game
from control feel is about as perfect of
a game as I can find is or but that's
just my heart the game skill bound yeah
has been delayed so do you have any
comment about it yeah can
I
do
first
I have a
tremendous amount of respect and
confidence in PlatinumGames and my
friend communist on I
would
it was great to get to work with them on
scalebound and we learned a lot from
both of us as we tried to make that game
what we both wanted it to be and in the
end we weren't able together to get it
there I would work with platinum and
Kamiya again I think they are a very
unique talent in the games industry and
somebody that I think is an important
part of the games industry
say for me and learning I think we
probably more than probably I I
announced the game too early before it
was the biggest game that platinum had
ever tried to build compared to their
other games just in terms of size and
multiplayer and scope so I think the
announcing of that game early put a lot
of pressure on the development and then
we kept showing it and it kept raising
the pressure and the bar kept getting
higher and we weren't going to be able
to deliver the game that our fans wanted
together so we made the decision both of
us to to not continue with it that said
you know I think where that goes in the
future we will see but it's a lot of
respect for the studio and learning on
my part because I know for our fans and
our customers announcing a game and then
not delivering it is not what they want
from me so it's good learning for me so
I think about eSports yes eSports is
getting really big as you know yes
taking over ng Windows PlayStation is
that the echo360 was asleep but a strong
player you what is your direction in
terms of you
yeah we've been really active in eSports
in a couple ways
one our first party games the halo World
Championships the gears eSport
championship I think we ran the
regionals for Gears just last weekend in
Las Vegas had great viewership on Twitch
great viewership on mixer I agree with
you I think eSport is a really important
important phenomenon that's happening in
gaming our acquisition of mixer and
building mixer into the windows and the
Xbox one experience is to make it easy
for anybody to stream click click and I
can stream
features like arena that we built into
Xbox Live lets teams integrate our
companies integrate matchmaking right
into the experience even at home because
now at home you have to one person takes
a picture the other person takes a
picture they have to send them in so get
cheating but now at the platform level
we can kind of arbitrate who wins and
what the actual scores were so if you
have tournaments that you want to start
in the home and then end up in the arena
windows is obviously an incredibly
important platform for eSports and we
continue to support a mixer and Xbox
Live on those platforms as well but our
first party teams I'm going to go from
here to
24 hour of Lamacq the race and we will
be doing the Porsche Porsche
championships we'll be doing them there
and the winner will be on the podium at
LeMond to 24 hours the winner of the
port city sport so I'll be part of that
because racing is also a growth a sport
racing is growing and forces such as
strong franchise there so our first
parties are fully embracing and as a
platform I think it's a very important
thing for us to keep in bed well when
you release the Xbox em yeah they were
talking about the VR yeah
doing something with all your eyes yeah
we didn't say that but there were rumors
yeah yeah so with X yes you have any
plans hololens or anything
i'm going to ask a question back in a
second so we can prepare but
our focus in mixed reality today is on
Windows and it's where we're seeing the
most developer interest and the most
gamer interest consumer interest because
it's easier I'm closer to my PC I don't
have my console under my television with
cords across the room as I'm trying to
play on a console there are more pcs out
there so we will have first party mr
games shipping this year with windows mr
we have four
head mounted displays for windows mr
shipping this year from our OEM partners
at very affordable prices compared to
what's in the market today that's
important so here at e3 we've stayed
focused on our console games some of our
PC games and our console and I will say
our customers have not
asked a lot about VR and mr like we
don't get a lot of push from our
customers to go focus more there I think
most of them see it as early but I'm
curious like from its array that do ru
you're from Famitsu right yeah that is
there a lot of VR interests that you
find from your readers in general yeah
yeah
we're not we don't get that much like
it's realistic in Isis the industry asks
more than our customers ask so unless
we we are kind of children today talks
are you mostly Japanese creators are
interested yeah yeah you know like oh
here's a mini ya know it's that's I went
when I was over in Japan I did the
Gundam VR experience which I thought was
very good and the
who was it that has that the Gundam any
other then yeah I've been a nympho yeah
in their Lobby right they know was they
had a room where they had him set up
skiing and but I thought the Gundam with
that you sit down on the hand and you're
picked up my the only one that's done
this
okay sorry but I do think
creators should be our focus
because we have a lot to learn about
what makes world-class mix reality games
today we're not there yet
that's why I look at Windows as a great
place for us to incubate and learn just
like gaming has started a lot of its
efforts on PC
for any of you were born way back when I
was still here but early days early days
and we are seeing that interest on
windows from creators so that is that is
where we're focusing our time and effort
but if you tell me if readers start
asking more than I want to know because
I want to pay more attention
okay thank you
what it's awesome interview with the
head honcho the master cheese of Xbox
still Spencer thank you very much for
that easy show for more coverage on E oh
yeah log go check out